nice daily from science mission
increased light exposure is linked to
obesity and scientist in the journal
PNAS report that this was caused by the
attenuation of noradrenergic activation
of brown adipose tissue rather than
increasing food intake or locomotor
activity prolonging day length decreased
the uptake of fatty acids as well as of
glucose by brown adipose tissue thereby
increasing the white adipose tissue and
obesity next scientists found that the
binge drinking in mines is promoted by
the absence of a g-protein gated
inwardly rectifying potassium ion
channel by blocking activation of reward
seeking dopaminergic pathway next
scientist introduced a
naturally-occurring mutation in the
Gamma globin promoter and show that it
causes binding of an activator tal one
chromosome looping and revival of fetal
hemoglobin expression in erythroid cells
which is important for various inherited
diseases for more details visitors at
www science mission calm or science
mission facebook page thanks for
watching